welcome to another episode of don't get
forked oh yeah my name is Ryan I'm the
club manager here and this show is about
showing puzzles that all involve Forks
we have contestants come up a lot of
employees and club members will come up
and they'll look at a puzzle and try to
figure out how the best way to not get
forked and just so there's no confusion
about what a fork is a fork is one one
piece attacks two other pieces any piece
can fork so all of our puzzles are
supplied by international master Eric
Rosen so thank you very much for that
and let's go to the board all right
round four of don't get forked with us
today is chess club tactical wizard
Jonathan whoo
shruts well I had a big pleasure I'm a
huge fan man I'm a huge fan I love
blunders as the grinders is great all
right wonders for a second flutters
what's the inaugural episode of our
youtube series but anyway I loved it all
right are you ready I'm excited man
really excited I mean I do it turn to
move okay okay
these make the best bow on the board to
not get bored that's like a tactic like
a tactic okay
tactical challenge if you will that
sounds good are you ready good you're
gonna turn around a 3-second see we'll
see you have 30 seconds figure it out
pretty nervous let me get the timer
ready three two one go
30 seconds a lot of stuff's going on
here there's your five Queen g5 there is
Queen g5 okay oh my gosh I might be
Queen Hey 20 seconds now we need reigns
a horse in one spoon ready to get away
of course this is a hard one so you
might get two for sure
all right sorry six six seconds you got
to give an answer okay Gilligan sir okay
I'm just great
I'm scared King bee one I believe that
is probably the best move on the part
yes yes this is this is really gonna
take me a long way your entire family
can eat yes I have a family of five and
we only have three forks at home well
you know what is this this is really a
case they'll also get a spoon all right
thank you for joining us don't get Forks
so check back all right thanks for
joining us on don't get cooked please
like share and subscribe to all our
videos and if you have any good fork
puzzles please send them to info at st.
Louis chess club org thanks